hey hey welcome welcome welcome in to
another exciting spellbinding
action-packed edition of Market takes we
have a just absolutely packed week of
data uh for you coming out this week but
I am going to tell you the three most
important things that you need to be
watching out for this week I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal this is Market takes I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me and I appreciate
that listen this week like I said we got
a lot coming but the first thing you're
going to want to watch this week we get
the U.S retail sales report I'm going to
tell you why that's going to be so
important this week uh next we get three
major reports on the U.S housing market
I'm gonna tell you what all three of
those are what to look for in those and
then we get some earnings reports from
big name retailers uh Home Depot Walmart
and Target all coming out this week uh
so we're going to hear a lot about the
US consumer the help of the US consumer
and that's going to tell us about the
U.S economy spending all of those things
because as you know those are what
really drive the U.S economy so let's
get into it first things first let's
talk about the U.S retail sales report
that is going to be out on Tuesday for
April I want to put this up here on your
screen right now just give you an idea
what we're talking about now as you look
over there on the right when we get into
2023 and those months leading into 2023
you see there that we have negative
month over month numbers so in November
December you saw retail sales were
negative then January we got a big
pickup up about three percent and then
in February and March we have seen a
decline again on those retail sales
numbers so that shown us right now that
we've got to worry some trajectory we're
seeing a consistent theme and a
consistent pattern as inflation has been
falling along with expectations we are
also seeing those retail sales numbers
again you those aren't pulled out those
aren't real numbers those are basically
not inflation adjusted so we are seeing
overall uh retail sales declining month
over a month for the last five months
and if we get another decline in April
that'll be five out of the last six
months we have seen again that last
month was down one percent after point
two zero point two percent negative uh
the month before economists are
projecting that we're going to get a
point eight percent increase in April
and so that would sort of buck this
trend we've seen But as you see there on
your screen consistently we've been
negative for the last five months I want
to put another chart up here on your
screen to just show you what this looks
like year over year and as you can see
just a consistent decline ever since we
hit that 10 percent number in July
retail sales have been have been coming
down coming in each month uh year over
year we're seeing a declining Trend and
so we're seeing that both month over
month and year over year and that just
illustrating the overall trend and
trajectory of retail sales is in
declining spending spending is pulling
back
consumers not buying as much really
getting some of that inflation fatigue
even as inflation has been coming down
and we're also seeing that combined with
another kind of worrisome Trend I want
to put another chart up here on your
screen here and this is the U.S initial
jobless claims this is the number of
people find filing for unemployment
claims or saying okay I've lost my job I
need to get on unemployment I'm
requesting for the government Aid in
that sector and as you see in 2023 the
numbers had been going down but we are
seeing a pickup and last week we saw
initial jobless claims at the highest
since October 2021. so the numbers still
low uh broadly overall we're seeing
still lower than lower than average or
lower than typical numbers on those
initial jobless claims but the the
trajectory we're seeing a pickup of the
trend and like I said the highest in
almost two years last week so still low
but that trajectory could be worrisome
and that's just that chart on your
screen right there is illustrating what
we're seeing in the initial jobless
claims Market in the unemployed
employment Market that could be
worrisome so let's talk about housing
housing AKA shelter was the biggest
component of core CPI inflation which
picked up more than expected last month
um we we saw and we have seen
consistently over the last few months
housing has been a major piece of the
overall inflation picture and this week
we'll get three more reports so we get
the nahb housing market index that's out
on Tuesday then we will get housing
starts that's out on Wednesday and then
the Big Kahuna existing home sales on
Thursday want to put a chart up here on
your screen to show you what we're
seeing in existing home sales and why
maybe this could be worrisome you see a
clear pickup in the home or the median
sales prices and the average price for
an existing home you're seeing a pickup
there and that's really what we've seen
all year is housing is starting to pick
back up in terms of price that chart
just illustrating a very clear short
term but a very clear
trend of housing prices starting to get
more expensive we have seen that start
to rise again and after that long-term
decrease that you saw also March marked
the first yearly rent price decrease in
36 months according to rent.com and it
followed six consecutive months of
single digit increases which means we
were seeing a consistent downturn in
terms of price increases however we are
seeing monthly rental rates increase 5.3
and in the last week of March according
to that same survey so again this is
just showing us the trend is picking
back up and we know we have seen
consistently going back for most of
about a year now
shelter or housing is a big piece of
that overall inflation picture and we're
seeing housing prices start to pick back
up that is despite a 75 percent increase
in inventory is in more homes being
built we are seeing more inventory on
the Shelf but we are more inventory
itself we're seeing more inventory in
the market is in more houses but that's
not bringing the crap the price down
because demand is still so high so
you'll want to watch out for each of
those reports with the big one being
existing home sales on Thursday last but
not least we get Walmart Target and Home
Depot earnings all out this week Home
Depot will kick things off on Tuesday
that's big because of what we just
talked about those prices for existing
home sales and we're seeing a consistent
increase in home builders those home
builder stocks have really just been
shooting up the charts seeing big gains
for home building companies uh but is
that translating to the real economy is
that making more jobs for folks are
folks going out and buying things to
furnish these homes or is that just an
investment boom is that just folks you
know who are delivering what was already
promised we will learn a lot about that
in those Home Depot earnings that we get
on Tuesday and that's going to tell us a
lot Thursday we hear from Walmart uh
that is the biggest retailer in the US
that's going to tell us a lot about jobs
about spending about how consumers doing
grocery uh General Goods how is Walmart
doing and that's going to tell us a lot
about how other retailers are likely
performing uh throughout the economy and
how much consumers are spending and
going out there and buying and then also
on Thursday we get Target we'll also get
TJX TJ Maxx Burlington those companies
they'll tell us about the kind of budget
conscious consumer so we're going to
hear from all three of those companies
this week you're going to want to watch
out for all those for what they tell us
about the market about consumers and I
think the market the stock market the
bond market all those markets that we'll
talk about on Market takes are going to
have some major reactions depending on
how these come in so that sets us up
tomorrow morning 10 a.m be here where we
unpack the retail sales report right
here on Market takes I'm your host Dion
Robert Bowen reporter at the Wall Street
Journal we hope to see you next time